hey guys my name is Jess behind the
camera there is Dan this is a mostly
empty office because we shoot this thing
at 7:30 in the morning Australia time
and year about the uses interesting
gaming you messed up a reason to look at
some pictures of a beetle for a handful
of minutes as images have arrived
showing off the power of project Scorpio
that's confusing I'm going to expect
Windows central obtained images show off
the visual boost that Scorpio will offer
over Xbox one the site shows off a
ladybug that has been rendered at 4k
using existing Xbox one assets
besides the same image that has vastly
improved textures utilizing Scorpios
extra GPU power see those little legs
overs and there's bug eye things and
stuff I did not pay much attention in
biology the full gallery over at windows
central also shows off what Scorpio can
do using the exact same asset so if you
want to check that out you can find a
link in our story on games list if you
like really good free games sony is
delivering a cracker of a month for
PlayStation Plus in May if you have
yourself a PlayStation Plus subscription
you can grab blood notes and portray all
three pirates and Merchants free on ps3
beginning me - on both Vita and ps4 you
can get laser disco defenders and
typewriter through cross-buy and on just
vehicle you can pick up the very pretty
and chlorine Abzu in north america while
alienation will take its place in europe
finally the best game telltale has ever
made in my opinion tales from the
borderlands and also coming to ps4 for
free this may Saudis as a favor and pick
it up from none of your dollars while
you're waiting be sure to pick up
April's free games which include drawn
to death and love it's in a dangerous
space-time finally we have our first
official details on the upcoming Call of
Duty Call of Duty 12 look to hustle
trailer along with details of the game
were revealed today via a live stream
2017 entry in the franchise which proves
that rust Cole is right and time is
indeed a flat circle we'll follow the
u.s. 1st Infantry Division as they fight
their way across Europe during World War
two you'll primarily play answer young
inexperienced
private
through missions like the d-day landing
and Battle of the Bulge
transformers actors Josh Duhamel will
also appear in the game as technical
sergeant William Pearson from Oklahoma
Apple multiplayer reveal is set for e3
in June but we do know a few details now
on the competitive side there will be a
brand new social space a large estimate
our headquarters it will feature
recognition and awards and serve as a
place for you to socialize outside of
multiplayer Lobby there will also be a
new wall mode which places you in iconic
World War 2 battles with objective
focused axis vs. allies between gameplay
for those of you who want a little co-op
in your card sledgehammer have confirmed
the zombies are making a return this
year to the latest iteration will tell
the story of the Third Reich's attempt
to create an army in the final stages of
the war Call of Duty World War 2 is
coming to ps4 Xbox one and PC on
November 3rd we'll be bringing you all
the Call of Duty news as well as
everything else from e3 in June so be
sure to subscribe to your caps upper
deck that is everything you've got who's
day do let me know what you thought of
today's stories in our comment section
and I will see with a bunch more news
tomorrow